as in going off because Bebe rexes had
it with her haters a video me popped up
and I was like let me read the comments
which you're not supposed that's the
number one rule don't read the comments
but I was like let me read the comments
and the first thing up top was BB rexha
weight gain and I was like the singer
now throwing some social media shade at
body shamers tweeting yes I'm in my fat
era and what
[Music]
BB's epic tweet came with this selfie
showing off her stomach you can have
your own opinions when it comes to
somebody else's body but
keep them to yourself she also shared
this a screen grab of search results
insulting her weight you know as the
queen of body positivity what message do
you have honestly just do you wear that
bathing suit wear that bikini even if
you gain those five pounds or you lost
too much weight or you have the stretch
marks where the beginning who cares who
cares you're gonna look back in 10 years
and say wow I was so hot
[Music]
gonna be okay
it's been about two months since Bibi
first put her Critics on blast posting
this pic and writing seeing that search
bar is so upsetting I'm not mad because
it's true I did gain weight but it just
sucks thank you to all the people who
love me no matter what
[Music]
bibi's been preaching about self-love
for years letting her fans in on her
personal struggles along the way
including her battle with polycystic
ovary syndrome more commonly known as
PCOS which causes her to gain weight you
don't know like what what like what
they're going through in their life so
it kind of is tough but I feel like
we're in 2023 like we should not be
talking about people's weight I like to
eat okay I like to eat and ain't nothing
wrong with that if you love me love me
[Music]
to believe you